la pression de la rue continue du vieux
port de Marseille bondé aux rues pavé de
Rennes ou encore à Toulouse
[Musique]
757000 manifestants dans toute la France
selon les autorités près de 2 millions
selon les syndicats à Paris la place de
l'Opéra point de départ du cortège s'est
rempli troisième mobilisation - suivi
alors face à des chiffres en recul les
syndicats brandissent la menace du
durcissement ne vous inquiétez pas si le
gouvernement maintient ses positions le
climat va se tendre et les grèves vont
se durcir ça c'est évident la réforme ou
la faillite est un argument d'autorité
qui ne convain personne et creuse un peu
plus encore le fossé entre les Français
et leur dirigeants politiques arrêtés de
prendre les gens pour des imbéciles
cesser de dire n'importe quoi soyez
utile cohérent efficace je sais je
demande ce matin l'impossible au
gouvernement aux infirmières poussière
au manutentionnaire à cette France qui
se lève tôt et qui va au boulot
qu'offez-vous deux ans deux ans ferme
formidable ambition vous faites pitié je
vais appeler le dernier le dernier
amendement de cette série qui est
présenté par Monsieur catenin
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues
en colère et Paris commence à gronder et
le lendemain c'est la guerre
nous avons eu pendant deux jours des
rappels au règlement des députés sont
sortis de cette émission parce qu'ils
n'ont pas gagné au tirage au sort et
quand l'un de leurs collègues qui a été
condamné pour avoir frappé son épouse
prend la parole sur un amendement vous
restez stoïque pire que ça vous
l'applaudissez on est c'est scandaleux
c'est nous vous avez 577 députés il y en
a un qui pose une question vous
n'entendez jamais la réponse vous sortez
de là avec ma malle de crâne parce que
ce qu'on entend à la télé et comment
vous êtes sur place
[Musique]
de crâne mais j'ai dit c'est pas
possible on est dirigé par des gamins
madame la président non s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas attrapé les pupitres la
parole est au gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
au début du 19e siècle Jean-Luc il était
coutume pour marquer l'un despendence
des femmes de leur laisser un petit
lapin de terre pour cultiver des oignons
afin de les revendre au marché pour
qu'elle gagne un peu d'argent merci
messieurs générosité elle n'a pas le
fluide de l'autorité je peux le dire
comme ça c'est à dire que quand elle
parle au fond bah c'est voilà tout le
monde s'en fiche alors évidemment quand
tu es Président c'est compliqué parce
qu'elle n'arrive pas à tenir ses troupes
ça existe le fluide de l'autorité
regardez et
alors commence dans les bras on va dans
les bras tu fais de la baline là allez
caméra a aidé on est sur la suite du
produit fétiche on est en Bretagne
semaine 7
dans ta chambre mais à la moindre
dispute conjugale évidemment ces
messieurs n'hésitez pas à leur rappeler
d'aller s'occuper de leurs oignons d'où
l'expression je le crois pas incroyable
je t'expliquer va t'occuper de tes
oignons monsieur le ministre vous voulez
deux ans de vie aux étudiants et à leurs
parents avec votre réforme des retraites
vous affamez dans les universités vous
écrasez les lycéens sous la pression de
parcoursup vous les condamnez par votre
inaction climatique vous les noyez dans
les chômage et le bas salaire vous
pensiez qu'ils allaient se laisser faire
non et vous venez d'admettre à demi-mots
que vous alliez continuer de les
réprimer vous les réprimer nous les
soutenons tu as eu
mais en tout cas ce dont on est sûr
c'est que dès la première ça use
beaucoup les salariés parce que deux ans
de vie c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
vol il y a pas d'autres mots le
gouvernement ne nous concerdra rien on
va gagner des victoires on va les
prendre on a aussi le sentiment que la
victoire elle est à portée de main elle
est à portée de basket et c'est
important de le dire aux Français on
avait bien compris le principe général
de votre question qui n'était ni
finalement sur les étudiants sur les
jeunes mais qui vous permettaient
d'avoir sans doute vos réseaux sociaux
les 15 secondes comme on dit Harol
évoqué pour chacun d'entre nous
c'est-à-dire un petit moment de
reconnaissance oui monsieur le député
vous faites vous êtes la caricature de
ce que j'essaie d'énoncer dans Le
Parisien c'est la bordélisation du pays
comme disait Samuel Beckett essayez
encore raté encore rater mieux qu'à
paupière
d'entre vous a déjà fait un métier
pénible qui d'entre vous peut lever la
main et dire moi aujourd'hui j'ai dû
pousser des chariots avec 50 de kilos de
ciment j'ai dû répéter 1000 fois le même
gestes en une seule journée qui peut
lever la main personne c'est vrai que
Rachel kéké concernant le métier pénible
elle est quand même plus appropriée que
Louis Boyard n'est qu'au début de son
histoire je te rappelle quand même qui a
énormément de députés qui ont commencé
40 50
tels qu'ils ont 25000 euros par mois en
cumulant tous les postes politiques
qu'ils ont eu alors qu'ils n'ont jamais
travaillé alors je voulais dire de
manière très sincères vous n'avez pas le
droit de mettre en genou les gens qui
tiennent la France debout habitué des
cortèges marseillais Jean-Luc Mélenchon
était à Paris aujourd'hui bonjour au
milieu de ces troupes l'ancien candidats
à la présidentielle appelle Emmanuel
Macron a recul c'est lui qui doit
maintenant se montrer raisonnable et
arrêter il faut qu'il fasse comme
d'autres
avant de tromper les quatre roues autre
chose comme idée on est dans un temps de
attendez une on va trouver un moyen de
plus en plus fort
lionel est top 50 vous ne le connaissez
pas c'est le seul journaliste en France
qui est en mesure de donner les chiffres
de la playlist de la manif
merci bonne journée la mobilisation ici
Arras qui se poursuit dans la bonne
humeur on a déjà eu deux fois les lacs
du Connemara c'est bien la bonne
ambiance
du Connemara deux fois donc merci Lionel
Top 50 voleurs dites de baisser un peu
surtout je hurle moi 5 minutes quoi
[Musique]
alors vous avez compris nous sommes en
direct et Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est sur
le piquet de grève de la gare de Lyon
j'aimerais bien pouvoir s'exprimer dans
des conditions un peu plus on entend
Manu Chao un peu plus simple en effet à
fond